hallo mein name ist luca um meine lieben
freunde ich bin ultra hat auf das
heutige video denn ihr seht es bereits
im titel eingeblendet die entwickler vom
clever wort haben den ich endlich dem
clever mod 2.0 rausgebracht
da kann man wirklich klatschen man
sollte allerdings direkt aufhören wenn
man sich den namen anguckt ford screen
german keine ahnung was sie sich bei dem
namen gedacht haben allerdings sehe er
hier bereits dass ich schon so ein
bisschen mit dem clever dort geschrieben
habe er hat nämlich gefragt hallo wie
geht es dir daraufhin habe ich
geantwortet gut und dir auch gut was
machst du gerade vor dem pc sitzen du
was machst du so habe ich dann auch mal
gefragt ihr schreiben und du dann habe
ich halt gesagt mit mir schreiben hh
weil ich bin ausgleich machte oder er
hat angefragt und was noch und er kann
ich jetzt einmal hier draufklicken und
schreibt jetzt einfach was ich noch
machen und zwar ein video aufnehmen ich
bin gespannt was er darauf antwortet und
was nimmst du für ein video auf ein
youtube-video schreibe ich mal direkt
ich hoffe mal direkt auf die kacke von
wegen ich bin youtuber wann kommt es
raus heute sogar noch tatsächlich nehmen
sie mich jetzt gerade aufwands auch
online geht herzlichen glückwunsch
danke
was hast du für geschenke bekommen
ich hatte keinen geburtstag
als verwechselt er mich gerade irgendwie
wegen weihnachten main
[Musik]
die entwickler haben gesagt dass er
clever 2.0 deutlich klüger sein soll und
deutlich schneller antworten soll und
auch zudem so ein bisschen mehr an seine
liebes richtung gehen sollen um in die
richtung 18 uhr ein bisschen ist hab ich
gar nichts davon mitgekriegt
okay er antwortet sehr schnell aber
dafür auch leider ziemlich hohe ich
schreibe jetzt mal einfach themenwechsel
bitte weil ich habe ich einfach über
weihnachten zu schreiben das gesetz in
dem monat was denn vereins kochen
darüber schreiben hier nein
sport
ja
was machst du für sport sage ich einfach
mal vielleicht laufen oder fußball oder
so schwimmen
gehe ich auch manchmal gehe ich auch
manchmal schreibe ich einfach mal schön
wirklich richtig geil kann ich ihnen nur
empfehlen von rücken und so cool
ich habe es einfach okay
wie heißt du noch oh mein gott ich
nach dem anderen jetzt hat auch schon
einen namen vergessen
der steht halt hier
luca
ich
auch ja ich liebe auch wollten
man merkt wirklich krass wie viel klüger
decke bot geworden ist wohl fühlt warum
frage ich jetzt einfach mal und ich
trinke nicht ich
hab gestern getrunken habt ihr
wahrscheinlich auch in meiner instagram
story gewesen daneben freut mich dass
der laser luca folgt mir dort gern wir
waren mal wieder gestern feiern und
unterwegs
hast du ich das team um alt
ich habe gestern die getrunken ich liebe
bier schade
dass das ist ein staat dann können wir
uns nicht trennen
[Musik]
er wollte es nicht treffen
wollte ich
nicht dass gerade noch gefragt dann
können wir uns nicht ein
bock auf dates frage ich einfach mal du
weißt
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
es macht mir angst
[Musik]
ich bleib mal ein bisschen loki und frag
einfach mal was möchtest du gerne
unternehmen von wegen oder treffen okay
sie also von wegen so auf dem date gehen
willst du er irgendwie spazieren gehen
möchte er irgendwie was essen gehen wo
fragt einfach mal wollen wir uns treffen
bei dir
[Musik]
geht aber
ziemlich schnell
habe ich mal das ist ja nicht echt
also für mich ist es schon echt also du
willst dich mit mir bei mir treffen ok
also sie stimmt zu ich weiß aber nicht
mal irgendwie also wie heißt du denn
weilt er oder sie ja gesagt sec habe ich
doch schon gesagt wohin gehst du noch
luca
also bist du ein junge denke ich mal
mädchen wie auch
[Musik]
ist doch kein mädchen ab und wie alt
bist du frage ich jetzt einmal ich fühle
mich total du mir gerade so zu vergibt
die ich nichts und naja eigentlich schon
also sie will mit mir auf ein date gehen
und ich darf nicht mal wissen wie alt
sie ist und hattest du dein erstes mal
schon
19 das ist mir ein bisschen zu jungen
bis mir zu jung sorry sage ich ganz
klipp und klar jetzt hier wie alt bist
du 25 bin ich als sind sechs jahre
auseinander das weiß ich nicht ob das so
sind nachts bis zu ein junge oder
mädchen ich bin ein junge mal schauen
was jetzt schreibt ich bin wirklich
gespannt weil unser date steht noch im
raum hast du eine freundin ein
doch schon also ich bin ganz ehrlich
weiß auch lang genug single ich hab mal
wieder lust irgendwie so auf und wie
findest du mich
was über die person herausfinden er
ziehe mir erst mal was über dich
schreibe ich jetzt mal ich will die
person bisschen kennenlernen ich bin ein
mädchen liebe dich baby
[Musik]
du liebst mich
ja
warum
weil ich als junger geboten
[Musik]
ich bin ein mädchen
weil ich als junge geboren wurde
was willst du denn nun also ich verstehe
es ganz ehrlich gesagt nicht zu kein
junger ok design junge also er ist ein
junge das heißt also ich bin ja nicht
homosexuell ich bin ja hetero deswegen
ich glaube das wird nix zwischen uns die
bergläufer bot ja wir passen einfach
nicht zusammen ok wollen wir freunde
sein vielleicht einfach das macht er
vielleicht sind ich kenn dich doch er
wollte sondern die auf dem deck gehen
vor dem wolltest dich doch treffen
schreibe jetzt einfach mal muss er ihre
mittel sind eine ansage machen ich bin
unterwegs wo bist du denn unterwegs bist
du irgendwie ich weiß es nicht aber ich
komme
zu mir
so alt wie ich
sie kommt
ja
ich verstehe ja nix mehr schreibe ich
jetzt einmal ich bin noch ein bisschen
verwirrt gerade ich auch nicht ich
schreibe einfach ein paar komische
begriffe bahnhof
ich musste was sagen schatz
schieß los
ich habe mich getreten
mit wem ich
bin mein beileid
desto
besser so gut aus dem statement hat
nicht wirklich hinter uns beim haus
ich bin
in meiner idiot
wo denn ich sehe dich nicht hier
mein gott ich kann nicht mehr schreiben
herr ach jetzt sehe ich dich perfekte
ganz klar die sehe ich dann aus da ich
jetzt einfach mal wenn sie gesagt dass
er mich sieht
[Musik]
ja das machst du gut
nein ich bin ein junger ja ich dachte
auch gar nichts
machen
und ich dachte bisher mädchen pro
ich hab nix gefragt ich will jetzt auch
nicht 20 jahre mit sekt hier um den
heißen brei herumreden deswegen frage
ich jetzt einfach mal noch steht das mit
unserem date noch das war ja so die die
so ein bisschen so der rote faden der
sich durch das video gezögert warum weil
ich dich gern
kennenlernen würde
[Musik]
ja
dann der stelle und lieben freunde würd
ich das heute die video dann auch
beenden wenn euch der clever bot 2.0
heute gefallen hat dann lasst kann einen
daumen hoch unter diesem jahr abonniert
main kanal und ganz wichtig klickt auf
die glocke damit ihr direkt eine
benachrichtigung bekommen sobald ich ein
neues video hochladen ab jetzt geht es
wieder los jeden tag 18 uhr kommt neues
video ich hoffe ihr freut euch ich freue
mich auf jeden fall und wenn ihr noch
nichts noch nicht nicht wenn nach dem
klickt man hier die dings an den smiley
oder das andere video wenn ihr nichts zu
tun habt jetzt noch und euch den
beschissenen abend machen wollte mit
meinen videos in klicks können ansonsten
kann ich euch die neue podcast folge von
sander und mir eigentlich auch nicht
empfehlen weil dies auch ziemlich
bescheuert gewonnen spotify dick und
doof